Welcome to the Beginning Ruby
nanodegree program.
I'm Walter.
>> I'm Colt.
>> And I'm Julia.
>> And we'll be your instructors.
Congratulations on taking your first
steps towards becoming a Ruby developer.
>> We've teamed up with industry leaders
to create a program that will help you
build the foundational skills you
need to become a web developer.
In this nanodegree program you'll
iterate on a series of projects for
your portfolio designed to get
you thinking like a programmer.
>> Our goal is for you to become
a self-sufficient programmer.
It's not simply enough for us to teach
you technical syntax in isolationw.
We want you to become a contributing
member of the Ruby community.
>> We'll be here to
support you along the way.
>> And before we get started, let's
first go over some general information
about what you can expect
from this nanodegree program.